best story oh
okay okay i mean we had a lot of great
stories
what were the nominations for this one
find out uh god was in a band
yeah that is a great story play the club
i was actually in a band myself i don't
i don't know if i've were you yeah i
don't know if i've ever talked about
this no you've never tried we've never
talked about it have i ever never
mentioned never mind what did you even
play yeah what did you play i play
guitar what seriously i'm i'm serious
why not started a band
no i was offended because i was like why
did you not tell me yeah we could have
started you're like years ago you're
like you were yeah how dare you not tell
me we could have brought back nine and a
half pounds years ago i know what the
hell yeah i mean like that was yeah that
was a fun story to tell just because i
completely forgot that i hadn't told it
before uh because i think i did tell it
on like a previous part or i mentioned
it
uh so i think i just assumed i had
already mentioned it before right right
um i was offended yeah
the boys went camping posted a couple of
photos of us going camping and uh so
many people thought they were like yeah
can't expect comics
no it's not always
thought that sometimes we just hang out
with our cameras
it's definitely like a full episode yeah
yeah but i mean we had so many good
stories from that cam trip though yeah
there wasn't like one story there's just
just like that that camp trip at least
it was just like a gold mine of stories
yeah and then there's qantas quarantine
hotels had armed guards wow this is what
made it they took us all the way from
haneda airport which is like very south
of tokyo yeah to ryogoku i could get to
this hotel and i [ __ ] you not there is
like 40 armed guards at this hotel
for like 20 of us it was ridiculous
i think one of my favorite things about
this story isn't like is the dichotomy
between like our two experiences i think
that what made the moment and the story
was just like the absolutely yeah yeah
honestly like a prison
and then oh this one
the [ __ ] memes come from oh and then i
look over and in the corner of my eye i
see a fat [ __ ] cockroach i just ran
in my room just like grabbed grab this
mouse pad that was the closest thing and
just ran back out
i grabbed the tit side of things right
whammy ones didn't work whammer twice
didn't work so i'm just like
[ __ ] like
truly degenerate moment god i love how
you had to mention that you were
grabbing the tits side i just i you know
when you just remember remember like the
most vivid details you know you know i
remember that feeling in my hand it felt
great
uh then we thought i managed to try to
scam us we couldn't find a clip for this
but like i remember the story where i
believe joey told uh the story
yeah maylin first emailed us and i
thought it was a scammy you thought it
was a scam because uh we didn't know
that book walker slash katakawa tried to
contact us yeah they were like big
company trying to contact small and
cheaper no like yeah yeah where's the
nigerian prince just just tell me where
the nigerian prince is okay right we
have a clip oh we do have a clip
remember the first time that may lane
message me like to work with bulk walker
yeah i thought it was a scare honestly
honestly i thought the same thing as
well
first one i [ __ ] deleted it
immediately i was like nah that's a scam
get out of that and then maylene misses
me like emailed me again after a week
and she's like i don't know if you read
my last email but uh we're interested in
working with you and i'm like
oh this [ __ ] shouldn't delete out again
i [ __ ] deleted that [ __ ]
and the final number and the final yeah
melin tried luring her cat with yogurt
oh this edit is amazing the moment you
open the yogurt cap he knows it's like
and then he's like
so i opened the yogurt and started
swishing around trying to make the
yogurt noises
and he finally came out
that's such a chaotic cliff
that would be a good like out of context
yeah that would be a great out of
context like just like joey just like
meowing in the background and mainly
just like so i tried to get i tried to
lure my cat out with yogurt
had an app that was apparently it would
translate what your cat is saying and me
and joe were like [ __ ] and so we
tried to
meow into it to see what it would be i
made it once yeah that was half of the
clip the second half of the clip was
just melin literally trying to know her
who was stuck in a wall behind you all
right she's so bizarre
like a joker it doesn't make sense like
you know when like you do something in
the dream and it makes sense in the
dream and then you wake up you're like
what the what kind of logic was that
that is literally that story that is a
dream yeah that's that's a fever dream
right oh man any of these could win
honestly
i would say
i i hope it's the main lean one just i i
jim we don't know maybe gone in the band
yeah john the band yeah cause that was
such a big deal yeah
that caused the stir yeah i think that
story dropped yeah i think that's like
that one was probably like most like
character development i guess is
yeah yeah in terms of like funniest i'm
just like mailing with a cat cause that
was the second time i'd heard it yeah
she told me that and i was like pissing
myself the first time she told me and i
was like maybe you gotta tell this on
stream it's like the best story ever all
right let's find out all right
tell us who won and the best story
goes to
god was in a bag
of course yeah
honestly surprisingly surprised
yeah uh i was in the band maybe i'll
pick up the guitar once again we're
gonna start a band man
we're gonna start off
what are you gonna do like triangle
yeah gun on guitar me on vocals conor
and triangle ten and a half pounds let's
do it yeah yeah i'm glad my band story
uh i'm glad my experience as a band uh
was good for something well what were
the percentages
god won that one with forty two point
four percent oh okay that's good
nice margin his epic battle with the
cockroach also came in second with 31
stories man
that's third place what's third place
third place was you guys going camping
with nine point eight percent okay okay
okay okay i mean that was just a story
gold mine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right well i guess uh what's the next
category oh i think i have it yeah yeah
what is it connor
biggest clown it's like okay so that i'm
doing this one so yeah so there's a lot
of clownery and trash taste as you know
as you know it's most
sometimes it is just clown taste
sometimes this is the circus yes uh like
most times actually sometimes sometimes
it's like when aren't we the circus so
obviously there is going to be our
biggest clown out of all of us all right
let's check out the nominations check
out the nominations
all right so that's oh my god these
pictures
so i guess me gone joey chris melina
iron mouse i guess because uh from the
charity stream yes oh my god
why is chris nominated twice guys yeah
what is that picture of you connor
[ __ ] hell
it's like mid exorcism i think it's
because i was playing
all right i love the shot of you joe
from like the spicy ramen challenge
going insane yeah yeah yeah yeah luke
did such a good job at that dude that
was literally like like a perfect shot
for like the go the anime character
going insane man
honestly we could all get these
uh so i have one i want chris to win
again i want crystal you won last time
oh [ __ ]
did you win
the other thing
that's just like selective memories like
chris won last time it's definitely
lovely christmas i definitely didn't win
let's see if you get two years in a row
then all right
i mean there's not much to say about
this you know we're clowns you know
we're all clowns okay who do you
do you guys think it's like between me
and someone
it has to be chris i i i think i have a
good chance of winning this yeah
oh sure like your clown
i think i was respectable like like not
like not respectable but like on equal
terms you know you know i said pizza
crust and all that but even that didn't
bring me to the clown category i just
think like the bread the bread the
breadstick was like so strong that was
like the solo carry you know well let me
have a peep first and i'll announce it
all right all right why why are you
peeping first right i tried a little
peep so i can do a dramatic reveal all
right [ __ ] it was me
[Applause]
why are you voting for me i'm not the
clown well you know well what are the
percentages let's find out what are the
percentages uh connor was the biggest
clown with 42.1 percent another vote who
came second uh god was the second
biggest clown with thirty three point
one percent
she's like majority is like
[ __ ] hell who was third who was gonna
slam it twice that was chris third was
chris all right
i'll take being suck you know what i
said the bread take i was literally
wearing a clown costume in the 24 hour
live stream and i still didn't win next
next 24 hour live stream i feel like
they're doing it just despite me
[Laughter]
how dare you like every like a
nomination like for the saltiest moment
every year should be conor winning the
biggest clown because he was very salty
last year so salty in fact that he's
forgotten about it he's just wiped it
from his memory now i thought chris was
i'm chris
this one i'm gonna repress this again
this is going in the repression memory
bank
all right the next one though is the
opposite it's the biggest chat it's the
biggest charge is that the opposite this
is the opposite of two persons yeah
there was no in between all right what
are the nominees what are the nominees
all right oh you got some nice photos oh
you got some nice photos okay but we
also got demon dice karen yeah ashley
come yeah um i mean i've i've put my
vote in for calm i put my phone for
comments
oh we have more as well yeah we have oh
some more
all right we got jan caisson mark lippy
chris broad and lake mega
you know that thing that doesn't exist
anymore i mean if we're speaking on like
literal terms there's probably like a
clear winner here right obviously it's
literally
literally the biggest
um but yeah i mean like i i got to put
in my voting for come i mean i'm putting
my vote for carl he
by himself i think we figured out he
donated like over there over ten
thousand dollars i think it was i think
it was over fifteen thousand over
fifteen thousand yeah so without without
him we would have like raised i think
like 180 000 it was total 180 000 total
so like he was 15 000 of that which was
like [ __ ] one man put in the world
yeah yeah yeah yeah one man putting the
world on the spot
and it is come yeah we still don't know
who you are but uh let's see who else
the biggest chad is of this year
the biggest chad of trash taste 2022 is
calm
well deserved only on trash taste will
you ever see a [ __ ] card that just
looks like
lowercase as well lowercase calm
thank you
thank you everyone give their thanks to
come we don't know who you are but you
are indeed the biggest you are indeed
the biggest well-deserved well-deserved
what was the percentage of come vote
come was 39.4 percent of them
i feel like if you didn't vote for come
you probably didn't know the context of
why [ __ ] was there yeah you missed out on
the charity stream no one knows what cam
is yeah but we're not hopeful that we
have it no one knows who comes no one
knows who it is what it is yes
but he definitely is not only the
current sigma but uh the the forever
signal
forever 2020 yeah
2020.
the same [ __ ] it's never
even been all right what's the next one
gone
um so the next category who's who is who
was like what was like the other
it's it's irrelevant it's okay okay
it's a relationship
is the biggest chat that's all you need
to know best nickname so like
wait are we pulling nicknames though
from last year no we're not there
these are the ones that were made
last year i oh i mean gone or me naming
gone steve
i thought it was karen yeah no no steve
jobs that won last year
i think we've realized who connor's
voted for by his selective memory i
didn't remember if that was a nominee or
not it was a nominee was it yeah i voted
you sure
i didn't vote i put 20 votes in i
thought it would be insider trading so i
didn't vote yeah yeah i thought jobs won
last year i mean so we get a lot of
memes and a lot of nicknames that come
out of our trash chase recordings uh i i
thought i actually thought this year
that
we didn't have any
nicknames i was like can we do we have
enough to get like nominations and then
i saw the nominations i'm like oh there
there's even more than last year
oh yeah we we had a lot okay let's let's
let's see them then that's one of the
nominations yeah
dr
okay we had
what a dr
legendary doctor legendary little baby
man little baby i mean i think that's
supposed to be gone but you know yeah
josh the monster
where did that come from
oh but for one i don't watch anime
anymore and yeah two one guy at the
convention called me josh on ironically
yeah so it was it was josh the man
now
and then obviously i've missed a raffle
of course of course next one oh
us
i mean that's not her nickname she is
our mother all right and then god god oh
that's your yeah that's that that was
someone mishearing my nickname and then
uh and then dc news easy news from the
trpg stream yes wow solid names i don't
know who's gonna win that's all
what was the first one again go back to
the first page
dr ligma dr ligma oh man i love doctor i
really hope little baby man doesn't win
i think if i was a betting man i'd
probably be at mister i would say mister
oh that one got a lot of mileage yeah
that was that was like like when when
chris came on and he said just said
affable now he's just known as like the
affable guy that that was the that was
the episode where everyone in the world
learned the word apple yeah before that
and then like now i can't stop using it
yeah
[Music]
uh yeah all right let's find out let's
find out who won man and the best
nickname of 2022
is
mr raphael
hey
good on you chris
you are mr affable you know the downside
of this it means that chris has a chance
to win more than one award
because he only won one last year yeah
sure sure he's going to be so made out
[ __ ]
all right what were the percentages
there well the top three just named top
three top three top was mr affable with
thirty two point seven percent of the
vote second was little baby man with
twenty point nine percent of them no
actually i'd say that thank you chris
thank you thank you thank you for thank
you
yeah
and josh the manga lab came in third
16.3 yeah god damn it that's all i
wanted to hear god damn it all right
fine